Rich Eisen had a great seat last night
did a great job
he's mr. Nashville NFL Network host the
Rich Eisen show on audience Channel 239
that follows ours in BR live.com how are
you feeling today rich DP I'm ready for
I'm ready for six more rounds to go
Haley really oh yeah oh yeah you know
I'm hydrated I'm stretched I only know
one speed like any day is what it is
what was the cool jargon this year the
jargon it I don't think it changed at
all it was a little twitchy twitchy made
an appearance actually I think it's
there was less jargon because Mayock
wasn't there who didn't get the we
didn't get the the oily hips we didn't
get the heavy legged waist bender he
works better in a phone booth we didn't
get any of that because miacca is
actually picking now whose strategy did
you question last night which team I
think he kind of hit on it right there
with the Giants but in the 15 years that
I've done this every single evaluator
I've ever been across as if you love the
quarterback you take him right where you
can the first possible moment you can
and that's why the Giants went with
Daniel Jones at six
I'm already but getting texts from some
buddies of mine back home in New York
that they're they feel fear that he's
the second coming of Dave Brown but you
never know you just absolutely don't
know he comes from Duke David Shaw who
sat next to me last night from Stanford
called
Duke coach Cutcliffe the greatest
quarterbacks coach in America obviously
he's tight with the Manning family from
their days at Tennessee so you put all
the all those together and they love him
they were probably fearful that maybe
Washington would get him and snagged him
when did you know that Kyler Murray was
going number one to Arizona until the
words came out of gödel's mouth I it's
nuts because we've never had a situation
like that obviously the last year with
Baker Mayfield we're wondering if
or Donald but it really could have been
a bunch of names that started off the
draft last night and on top of it the
intrigue about where Josh Rosen was
going I would have I would have put the
number the percentage of of where the
Mauri being taken and Rosen being kept
by the end of night I would have put
that in the single digits of likelihood
a percentage 5% something along that
lines I'm stunned that Rosen is still on
that team right now I'm stunned that the
Cardinals did not have something in
their right or left hand drawer that's
been planned over the last week or so to
just pull out and say the minute we take
Murray who wants them if we take him and
then just have the bidding
behind-the-scenes and if it's known that
they were bidding on Rosen well it
doesn't matter because they're taking
their guy it just makes no sense
Rosen is still on that team right now
down Robert Clem Coe Monday Morning
Quarterback he just tweeted out the
Cardinals GM Steve didn't start taking
calls in text on Josh Rosen trade until
minutes before the draft started /
sources and Rosen's value diminished
with every pick as a result nobody came
close to offering the first-round pick
the Cardinals were seeking I had heard
it was three weeks ago where I was told
nobody is giving a first-round pick to
the Cardinals for Josh Rosen and I would
have thought now the leverage goes back
down unless you're gonna go well
somebody's after the first round or
maybe the second round they go we didn't
get our guy or a guy now we'll trade for
Josh Rosen maybe you have a little
leverage I just don't know what the
Cardinals you know what that stance was
what the philosophy is going into Josh
Rosen situation yeah it's exactly right
and now you've got a kid who is very
upset
there's just no other way to put it and
you know for him to still be on this
roster right now makes no sense
I had Mariucci on my show the other day
and
is it possible that they they could keep
Murray and Rosen and he called that
gasoline and matches those were the
three words that he used because not
only are you gonna have a young kid in
the quarterback room whose job was just
taken from him but also on top of it you
got a kid who's smart stuff to be able
to verbalize this in a way or
internalize it in a way that just might
make it even worse
so he's handled it nothing but
professional so far and and I've been
given every indication that he's going
to continue to do that that way and I
don't know if Miami's gonna bail them
out that's the only way to determine it
right now is bail them out
you know because everything I've heard
and I'm sure you have every possible
play they can by winning as many games
as they possibly can and still winding
up with till next year I know so I don't
know how they'd pull that off but I
don't think they're gonna scrap all that
unless they could get Josh Rosen for
pennies on the dollar which it looks
like he's gonna have to be available for
what do you expect to happen tonight I
expect to see a ton of quarterbacks go
I mean a ton they were hardly taken
there's a few tackles to be to be had I
expect a ton of trades and and just
another great night I mean it is a party
here Dan it is just amazing it really is
not as you compare it how would you
compare that atmosphere what do you say
how would you compare the atmosphere of
last night to other like Philly Chicago
some of these other there's nope there's
no comparison because those other places
were just a draft Hall dropped into a
beautiful park or on on the iconic steps
of an art museum where they created with
tenting and just other other makeshift
museums with NFL artifacts in tents
around a park or a street or in last
year a parking lot of an NFL stadium
this is already like a dynamic vibrant
party spot that's top five if not top
ten in America to go hang out and just
party in and just dropping the draft in
it and it's amazing and it's a football
crazy spot obviously Philly in Dallas
and Chicago are two but just putting it
all together that was nuts last night
and I think the NFL is going to get an
idea here to continue making this bigger
by dropping the draft into already
iconic places that you can somehow
cordon off security wise and I'm hearing
Fremont Street in Vegas next year and I
think that's the mode that they're going
to go right now from now on if they can
great job last night enjoyed the watch
and we'll be watching tonight you're the
man keep you thank you buddy
that's Rich Eisen NFL Network host for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on VR live or download the Dan
Patrick show at